on va parler fromage alors après on a
fait le poisson le le le foie gras et
canard fromage avec l' du Vic bisou
donc tout un fromage c'est ça tout un
fromage à à rembouiller alors vous vous
avez un itinéraire absolument incroyable
c'est dire que vous ah bah si vous avez
fait des études de commerce étiez
consultant stratégie vous au cadre
supérieur quoi dans l'industrie et puis
à à quel âge à 43 ans je crois hein vous
dites
mais vous aviez une passion pour le
fromage déjà très jeune hein j'avais une
grande passion pour le fromage et je
voulais absolument que le fromage a une
place pas que dans ma vie privée dans ma
vie professionnelle et comme on a qu'une
vie et bien j'ai fait en sorte de de
mettre le fromage dans ma vie pour la la
oui la deuxième partie de mon parcours
professionnel c'est ça et c'est donc ça
c'est en 2009 he c'est ça c'est ça oui
euh donc vous ouvrez tout un fromage à
rembouiller je reprends une petite
boutique qui a des gens qui partaient à
la retraite qui étaient déjà bien
établis et je la rebaptise tout un
fromage en 2010 effectivement 2010 voilà
et alors c'est pas fini si je peux dire
parce que en 2013 euh vous dites bah
pourquoi je passerai pas le le le
concours de meilleurs ouvriers de France
oui je me dis que bah je suis ma passion
est intacte et j'ai besoin d'un
aiguillon pour continuer à travailler à
progresser à m'améliorer et pour pas
passer du côté d'une petite routine qui
pourrait être la routine du petit
commerce voilà et donc je je m'inscris
au concours et après comme je suis un
compétiteur j'ai fait j'ai fait ce qu'il
faut pour parce que c'est c'est c'est
très compliqué il faut dire oui oui
c'est un concours d'excellence il y a
quoi il y a 13 épreuves je crois c'est
ça c'est ça il y a 13 épreuves en
plusieurs phases qui font le tour de
tous les savoir-faire autour de notre
métier quoi quoi par exemple comme
épreuve euh bah vous avez par exemple
minable
non vous avez pu on connaît ça dans le
vin vous avez une épreuve de dégustation
à
l'aveugle faut reconnaître le fromage et
donner son âge ah oui alors en qcm pas
mais on vous demande si c tel le produit
il a 6 mois 10 mois et cetera vous avez
des épreuves de
composition artistique de présentation
de mise en valeur parce que notre métier
de crémier fromager n'est pas un métier
de fabric
cont camarad ici mais c'est un métier
d'expertise de sélection de maîtrise de
l'affinage et de mise en valeur du
produit et alors vous êtes fromag
affineur on dit aussi non c'est ça oui
affineur c'est-à-dire que alors je
personne n'est complètement affineur
dans le sens où dans une boutique où
vous avez 100 ou 150 fromages personne
ne peut prétendre à affiner sur place
tous ces produits donc l'affinage pour
moi c'est une compétence mais qui
s'applique à une partie de notre gamme
où on on rentre des fromages euh à un
état plus jeune qu'on va faire mûir et
qu'on va faire évoluer euh plutôt
crémeux plutôt plus sec
aromatisé humidifié par un brossage et
cetera des soins d'affinage mais ça ne
concerne pas tous les produits je prends
un exemple très clair le compé il est il
s'affine très très bien dans ces
immenses caves cathédrales en Fran
compté je reçois des meules de compté
prêtes à être coupées pour mes
ou avant chez vouster avant chez vous ça
ser à rien ça serait ça serait puisquil
il s'affine très bien tout seul très
bien chez les spécialistes
absolument un mot sur la c'est parce que
une question un peu de be je me suis
toujours poser comment vous conservez
les fromages dans une fromagerie parce
que moi quand quand je mets des fromages
chez moi par exemple je les mets au
frigo après ils sont ils sont moins
bons comment on
fait disons que chez vous chez les
particul
B pour conser le fromage parce que le
frigo c'est un peu trop froid et la cave
qu'on peut avoir éventuellement sous la
maison c'est un peu trop chaud que on
met pas dedans la bonne fenêtre c'est
c'est entre 6 et 10 degr d'accord donc
les fr donc vous avez des des donc on a
des des installations des chambres avec
de l'affinage de l'humidité et une
température régulée pour bien conserver
les produits et ensuite on va jouer sur
la ventilation la protection ou pas des
produits par rapport au flux d'air voilà
et donc effectivement mon message c'est
n'essayez pas la maison de conserver
très longtemps les fromages vaut mieux
acheter moins mais plus souvent
absolument non mais moi c'est c'est vrai
que c'est c'est c'est le conseil qu'il
faut donner parce que c'est il est
meilleur quand on quand on le sort de
chez le fromager qu'on le mange après
pour quelques jours heinprès voilà on pe
garder un peu trop longtemps c'est pas
c'est pas terrible quoi c'est pas
terrible alors j'ai vu qu'il y avait on
va parler après des des des fromages que
vous avez apporté mais j'ai vous que
j'ai vu il a il y a un Briis des
zivelines alors oui nous avons dans les
zivelines une belle fabrication de
fromage alors c'est on n'est pas une
grande région de fromage de là mais nous
avons un très beau producteur dans le
sud des Yvelines qui s'appelle la ferme
de la tremblae à la Boissière école
limitrophe heuréloire
avec un élevage de vache et de chèvre
d'accord et de très bons produits dans
un dont un Briolet cru euh un petit de
fermier fermier comme que donc le
rentochin avait raison d on trouve tous
les produits on trouve du fromage dans
les du fromage dans les evvelines et
puis celui qu'on trouve pas dans les
evvelines on peut venir l'acheter à tout
un fromage à rembouiller alors vous avez
pas porter alors ça c'est des fromages
que vous conseillez un peu pour les
fêtes ouf pour la RA pour la saison en
tout cas oui ce sont des fromages que je
conseille pour la saison et ça il y a
une saison hein pour les fromages il y a
une saisonalité pour le fromage soit une
saisonalité complète pour quelques
produit on connaît le mondeor qui n'est
disponible en automne hiver et la
saisonnalité des fromages c'est plutôt
une petite sinusoïde qui fait que selon
la période de production le le lait est
moins moins riche moins aromatique et
donc le fromage peut être un peu
meilleur quand il est produit notamment
avec de lait à partir d'herbes quand les
animaux sont nourris à l'herbe ah
d'accord voilà ah oui il faut que oui et
ça vous savez aussi d'O d'où viennent
enfin connaissez vos producteurs
évidemment h très on le rend visite on
suit l'évolution des produits sur le
cycle de l'année évidemment vous avez
qu'un producteur par fromage ou vous
avez
plusieursp ça dépend dans la plupart des
cas oui et dans certains cas j'ai un
producteur et un pas une roue de secours
mais oui un coproducteur un deuxème
choix parce que effectivement certains
produits sont pas tout à fait réguliers
ou disponibles toute l'année mais c'est
c'est aussi le charme des produits
fermiers le pro d'un produit fermier
c'est qu'il n'est pas
toujours homogène cordau toute l'année
d'où l'importance de venir dans dans par
exemple chez vous he il y en a d'autres
évidment et d'avoir les conseils les
conseils de de voilà de du fromager hein
c'est important alors euh bah peut-être
je vous laisse décrire les les que vousz
alors je précise quand même puisque on a
suivi un peu la séquence du repas et
c'est très bien mais qu'on peut aussi on
a le droit de commencer par le fromage à
savoir qu'el apéritif le fromage et
particulièrement moi je j'adore ça parce
qu'on a les papilles et l'appétit
entièrement disponible et on apprécie
particulièrement le fromage quand on
commence par lui alors c'est un peu une
façon de tirer la couverture à nous mais
mais voilà n'ésite commencer par vous
voilà bah retenez cette petite
formule retenez cette formule voilà un
apéro sans fromage c'est trop dommage
donc on met du fromage à l'apéro non
c'est vrai que c'est une bonne bne très
bonne idée et bien ici qu'est que vous
Prz fromage à laapéro par exemple
comment et comme fromage vous ah benah
on peutu près tout euh selon deux
modalités soit les fromages à pâ de dur
qu'on va couper en petit cube en petit
frand qu'on prend à la main ou bien euh
ou bien l'inverse presque le côté en
tartine du coulant du crémeux du mond
d'or du Saint Marcelin du du Gor gonzola
du Rockfort tout ça peut se tartiner sur
des petits toastes je crois qu'on disait
d'ailleurs le le le le le le
[Musique]
le le Rockfort par exemple avec du du
porto je crois que c'est c'est oui les
les les pâtes persillées notamment les
plus puissants se marient très bien avec
des vins un petit peu sucrés plus sucrés
hein c'est ça ou oui les les muscas
Moris Porto et ce oui alors descrip VO
une sélection pour les fêtes mais qui
n'a rien de
d'impos où j'ai repris quelques quelques
un de mes coups de cœur on va commencer
par les
Yvelines puisque notre ferme de la
trembla
qui parit tout à l'heure avec leur bris
vient de sortir un nouveau produit que
je trouve magnifique et très réussi
alors vous allez deviner son nom quand
on voit son aspect il s'appelle le pavé
de Paris et c'est simplement ah c'est et
pour le faire ils sont se sont baladés
un jour dans Paris et ils ont pris un
pavé sur un chantier ils l'ont ramené à
la ferme et ils ont travailler longtemps
pour avoir cette croûte cette texture
cette couleur qui imite exactement la
forme de du pavé parisien ah c'est
magnifique ça ça c'est la croûte hein
alors ça c'est la croûte et à
l'intérieur ben on le coupe en petit CUB
voilà et c'est un mélange en fait de
vache et de chèvr mais c'est pas un
mélange de lait c'est un mélange de
cahier c'est-à-dire dans un stade après
ce qui fait qu'on a des marbrures jaunes
et blanches parce qu'on a agrégé de
cahiers le le cahier de chèvre a
tendance à être plus blanc et le cahier
de vache un petit peu plus jaune donc un
magnifique fromage voilà avec une belle
magifque pas pas très connu donc pas
très connu parce qu'il est à la fois
nouveau mais il est promis un bel avenir
moi je l'adore
gustativements il est très réussi il est
amusant je suis sûr qu'il va faire c'est
une bonne très belle idée il va faire un
carton
ensuite euh B
on va rester en île-de-fance avec un BRI
de maot garni à la truffe oui alors ça
c'est le mais c'est bien la truff dans
le fromage oui c'est bien à petite dose
hein moi voilà pas trop moi j'ai deux
produits sur 150 fromages et deux
produits à la truff pour en proposer
mais je suis pas voilà je suis pas parce
que je trouve un moment c'est devenu la
mode S la truff quoi oui oui c'est c'est
parfois c'est un petit peu trop et on se
met à truffer des
fromages avec la truffe quoi
oui c'est pas la peine de déper de
l'argent pour oui oui on va bientôt
avoir de la truffe au bris magif oui
c'est ça alors le BR Le Bris c'est
magnifique ça peut être aussi le bris à
savarin des fromages qui ont C cette
onctuosité ce crémeux euh qu'on vient
garnir dans leur milieu avec un mélange
de crème type
mascarpone et des lamelles de truff et
donc là c'est un voilà c'est un beau
produit festif bon parce que voilà VO ou
euh ensuite et bien on va aller en
Bourgogne moi je suis bourguignon de
naissance donc je je fais rarement un
plateau de fromage chez moi son fromage
de Bourgogne c'est un petit fromage
magnifique à croûte lavée que j'adore
qui s'appelle le fermier au chaeli
fromage de vache lavé au Chabeli et on
boit du Chabeli avec ou pas alors on
peut on on pour reparler du vin avec le
fromage on peut boire du blanc ou un
rouge léger mais effectivement si on
déguste ce fromage avec un vin autant
aller sur un blanc type
oui ça on peut on peut boire du vin
blanc avec les fromages ah oui oui oui
oui il y a un fort consensus d'ailleurs
des someliers des onologues
restaurateurs sur le blanc avec le
fromage donc ça c'est le fermier au Chab
un petit fromage qui avait disparu qu'on
a ressuscité avec son affineur Pascal Le
rou dans
Lyonne un bleu que j'apprécie
particulièrement qui est très élégant
subtile dans son persillage comme dans
son goût qui s'appelle la fourme de
Monbrison qui pas la fourme d'env la
forme d'Amber qui est une autre forme
d'appellation et qui Monbrison c'est pas
c'est pas Montbrison c'est donc dans la
Loire c'est à la frontière entre le
massif central et puis la le le le
Lyonnais et c'est un très joli bleu et
pour évoquer les yvelin j'aime bien
penser que son persillage très fin comme
ça bleu un peu clair pour moi il évoque
la toile de jouille donc c'est voilà
c'est on revient on revient à laerie du
coin et enfin à tout seigneurs tout
honneur le
compé produit phare noble excellent s'il
en est qu'est-ce qu'il faut prendre il
faut prendre quoi du du affiné depuis
alors ici je vous ai proposé un compté
affiné 30 mois 30 mois c'est le plus non
c'est pas le plus on peut toujours faire
plus mais après parce qu'on trouve quoi
12 18 30 qu ah bah on trouve tous les
mois possibles hein ça dépend quand il a
été fabriqué plus plus il y a de mois
d'affinage plus il est fort c'est ça oui
il devient plus puissant plus boucané
éventuellement plus salé moi je
considère que le compté passer 3 ans
c'est c'est excellent mais ça devient un
autre produit c'est autre chose les
notes typiques du compté s'expriment
vraiment jusqu'à 30 30 36 mois après ça
devient aut chose chose ou donc là on a
30 mois un produit fabriqué donc au
printemps 2021 affiné au fort
Saint-Antoine ah oui Pontarlier et euh
et là on a la plénitude on a les petits
cristaux de protéines qui font ce petit
croquant sous la dent et des arômes
voilà très très expressifs très longs
voilà il en parle bien
hein